I like to get it wrong.
We have won eight consecutive
world championships in a row
and hasn't been done by any
other team in any sport.
It's difficult enough to win one,
and I think we have been able
to set the right objectives
every single year with the team.
I believe that we simply got it wrong.
Toto Wolff is one of those,
"If you know, you know" guys.
In lots of places, he'd pass as a typical,
successful global businessman,
a well dressed, multilingual
guy on the move,
but for a growing segment of
the sports obsessed world,
he's a "Guess who I saw"
whip out your phone to prove it celebrity.
The CEO, co-owner, and team principal
of the Mercedes-AMG
Petronas Formula 1 team,
Wolff commands a billion
dollar enterprise,
one that's implanted itself
into racing fans consciousness
with an unprecedented run of success,
a run that just at least took a pause.
We knew that at a certain stage
that winning streak is going to end,
but all of us see this as a fantastic test
because with all the business issues
and problems and challenges
that need to be faced,
keeping the cool under pressure,
trying to believe in
the science and trust,
it's physics, it's not mystics.
But giving it the necessary
time and understanding
that you can't accelerate
learning to a certain degree.
That's fantastic.
Formula 1, it is one of
the most difficult sports
to succeed in.
Literally everything has to
come together, man and machine,
within these race weekends
and the margins of success
or failure are incredibly,
incredibly small.
We're talking about thousands of seconds
that could make the difference.
I'm not worried about anything
in my professional life.
Things happen for a reason.
My perspective is beyond 10 years,
it's not just a single race.
The weekends or the races we lose
are the ones our competitors
will regret the most
because we learn the most.
It's gonna make us better.
In racing, if you're not
winning, you're losing.
It's just that simple.
And after one of the most trying years
in the team's history, Wolff
is hell bent on showing
he still knows how to win.
Monaco occupies a quirky spot
in the collective global imagination,
yachts, casinos, and of course fast cars.
It's tiny, the second
smallest country in the world.
So small that when you're
driving in from the airport
in nearby Nice, if you miss the exit,
you could end up in Italy theoretically.
Like the signage has changed.
Once you're there,
it has a fairytale quality,
right down to the palace
that sits on the hill
overlooking the the harbor.
There's an actual prince
living there with his family
and Prince Albert's family has long been
beyond supportive of the sport
that put Monaco on the map,
but I'm here to meet up with someone
many consider modern F1 royalty.
I got you.
Copy me.
What they used to do in the
past is that they just drove
with doors open,
but they need to be careful
that you're not crashing anybody out.
Pedestrian as well.
Wow.
And leave it open.
That is much more pleasant
on a hot day in Monaco.
I mean obviously this
car attracts attention,
but you now attract attention.
Actually, it's an
interesting life experiment
for me because I'm not a sports person
that grew up with that.
I think let's close it for the time being.
That kind of public persona
happened to me much later
in my life where I think my
character was already done
and couldn't influence
me in a negative way.
It shows that the popularity of the sport
and of the team and public recognition
will be always something
that is flattering
and you mustn't take it for granted.
Tell me about Monaco.
I mean this is the cradle
in many ways of this sport.
How do you view it?
Formula 1 is Monaco.
Monaco is Formula 1.
If you ask someone that
has heard about Formula 1
and knows a little bit about it,
they will associate Formula 1 with Monaco.
It's by far the most popular race.
Now, obviously Miami was
great and Las Vegas coming in,
hopefully they're gonna go,
they're gonna be big as well,
but Monaco was always a glamorous town
that was known for Formula 1.
Wolff, who grew up in Austria,
picked up racing at 17,
but by 1994, his performance on the track
sent him searching for another challenge.
He looked to business.
As a young man, if you
can't be a racing driver,
you'd like to be an investment banker.
That at least was I how it happened to me.
In the late 1990s, the
internet came out and with it,
the boom of startup businesses
with valuations going astronomical,
a little bit to what we have experienced
until most recently.
And I jumped on that bandwagon.
Through investing firms
MarchFifteen and MarchSixteen,
he enjoyed the success of the dot com era
and also the less sexy world of investing
in industrial companies.
His success in the
investment world allowed him
to get back into the business of racing.
And then came the call.
Do you want to become a partner
in a Mercedes Formula 1 team?
And literally, I had to pinch myself.
I'm very excited, obviously,
to be representing
Mercedes-Benz in Formula 1.
In 2013, Toto would take over management
of the Mercedes F1 team,
but his investments in the team also meant
that he would own about a
third of the overall franchise,
a good investment considering
under his leadership,
the Mercedes team would go
on an unprecedented run.
Lewis Hamilton would win seven straight
Drivers' Championships and
Mercedes would win eight
Constructors' titles.
That's the team prize that
takes into account point totals
from each team's two drivers.
It was a level of
domination rarely seen in F1
or any sport for that matter.
Toto would also turned the sport
into a true family business.
Marrying his wife Susie,
herself a former British pro driver.
She most recently ran a team
on the Formula E Circuit.
That's the electric
car division of the FIA
the governing body that
also includes Formula One.
I got to catch up with the
couple just over the border
in France with a view
you might only get dining
with the ultimate motorsport power couple.
So what is it like for
the two of you to work
in the same business?
Well, I can't speak for Toto,
but I certainly, I love what he does.
I'm, I'm very, very proud.
But I also love following
it from the sidelines
of watching the races,
coming to some races.
But I also love, I mean, from him,
I learned so much over the years,
which was part of the reason why I felt
that I could take on
the role in Formula E.
Susie started racing
even earlier than Toto,
when she was about eight years old,
decided to become a racing
driver at the age of 13.
Susie and Toto's paths
crossed when she was
with Mercedes-Benz and
German Touring Cars.
I went to a race in New York
and I remember standing
being able to see the Statue
of Liberty with these electric racing cars
and obviously then Diesel-gate happened
and everything sped up in
the automotive industry.
And then I thought,
this has got something.
And I literally just copy
and pasted Toto's deal
with Mercedes said, "Okay,
I don't need a salary,
but I want equity."
I remember there was one
instance at the beginning
in Formula E, we were struggling
and I had both cars in the
top and one after the other,
they all stopped with the same
problem with the drive shaft.
And I was getting phone calls from people,
obviously very unhappy
that we had this issue.
And then I called Toto and
he said, "What happened?"
I said, "We have this issue
with the drive shaft."
And he said, "Sort it."
I said, "Well, yeah, I better try sort it,
but I'm not the technical director.
I don't even know what the issue is."
And he's like, "It's your
problem, you have to sort it."
But it was also in that
moment that I realized
that the buck stopped with you.
It's about very quickly fixing
issues and finding solutions.
During his tenure with Mercedes,
Wolff has become a master
at solving problems
and managing talent, including Hamilton,
indisputably the most
famous driver on the circuit
over the past decade.
Wolff's role as both owner and manager
of a record setting sports
franchise is unique.
Imagine if the Patriots'
Robert Kraft and Bill Belichick
were the same person
which is how Toto ended up
teaching a case about himself
at Harvard Business School.
Someone like a Toto Wolff,
any team principal really,
is responsible for
hundreds of people, right?
Mercedes has 1800 people
across the factory
and the unit where they
actually look after the engines.
So 1800 people who he has to manage
and what struck me is
the remarkable attention
to detail that he brings to the table.
The governing body, the FIA,
is set up to not have anyone
win eight times in a row.
This is all about trying to
maintain a competitive balance.
So against all those odds
in an incredibly difficult environment,
the Mercedes team was able to
keep a winning streak alive
for eight years.
That I thought was a
really interesting premise
for a case study.
Anita Elberse is a Harvard
Business School professor
specializing in the
intersection of entertainment,
media, and sports.
She's written case studies
on figures like LeBron James,
Maria Sharapova, the Rock, and Beyonce.
Putting people at the center,
analyzing mistakes very rigorously,
having an open atmosphere in
which everyone can speak up
if they see something
that needs to be fixed,
and then also actually
having the willingness
to try to fix what has been going wrong,
this relentless pursuit of winning
and never giving into complacency.
The last 10 years have been
a critical growth period
for Formula 1 racing.
Spurred by the $4.4 billion purchase of F1
by John Malone's Liberty Media in 2017.
Toto saw firsthand how much the ambition
for the sport accelerated.
With Liberty coming in,
although we were skeptical
at the beginning,
that's where we really started
to have this massive upswing
and together with the
governing body, the FIA,
we were able to put on
a show during Covid,
that's the only global sport
and it obviously helped a lot.
The business of Formula 1,
it's a bit more complicated
than it might seem
from just watching a race.
There's the global governing
body for the 10 teams,
each of which is an
independently run business.
Like pro basketball or football teams,
each has its own ownership group.
Those teams get cuts of
overall Formula 1 revenue
based on each season's performance.
Those teams also have
sponsors who pay for the right
to have their names on the cars, helmets,
or other team materials like crew shirts.
Finally, there are promoters.
They buy the right from F1 to host races
in individual locations,
usually for several years at a time.
They recoup their money and earn profits
from selling hospitality
and other sponsorships.
Since buying F1 in 2017,
Liberty has grown revenue
for the circuit by 20%,
despite a global pandemic.
Revenue totaled $2.1 billion in 2021.
Being a shareholder in a
company and managing it,
it is always about profitable growth.
Nevertheless, the biggest
part of the return
on investment was the advertising value
that we generated from
Mercedes and our partners.
Lap time and performance always
outweighed profitability.
Perhaps the biggest change came
with a radically
disrupted media landscape.
So it's helpful to have one
of the world's most influential media
and communications
companies as your owner.
What are you doing?
Just sending good vibes.
And he is through.
See you later.
Social media, staunchly resisted
by the previous management,
became a new vehicle for
promotion and to connect teams
and drivers to their fans,
augmenting, even supplanting,
the once stodgy single
broadcast for each race.
Now instead of engaging a
couple dozen Sundays a year,
fans had deep and direct ongoing access.
And then there was that show.
All I do is pray for a safe race.
You need to respect the
speed for the second.
A driver has fear, you need to retire.
The Mercedes team wasn't included
in the first season of "Drive to Survive."
That was Toto's decision.
One of the reasons I didn't want to do it
'cause I didn't want our
engineers and drivers
to act like in a movie
Yeah, right.
rather than being fully
concentrated on the job.
While capturing failures on camera
might not have been ideal
for Toto and his team,
for the sport of F1, it's
been a massive success.
After seeing what one
season did for the sport
and his rivals,
he signed up for season two
and an entirely new level
of fame and notoriety for his
team and for him followed.
It launched a boom
and it opened up a
completely new audience,
different to the hardcore fans,
especially in the United States.
With Austin and Miami
already on the calendar,
in 2023, F1 will return after
four decades to Las Vegas
for a nighttime race
that will include the famous Vegas strip.
It's quickly becoming one of
the hottest tickets in sports.
With the three US races
and five in North America,
including Montreal and Mexico City,
the sport is building
a massive US audience,
which is always part of
Liberty Media's business case.
The races on US soil are
proving wildly popular
in terms of attendance,
drawing some of the biggest
crowds across the circuit.
Miami in its first year
attracted 330,000 fans
across the weekend.
Austin was the single
biggest event of the year
with 440,000 spectators.
We arrived in Miami and there was
lots of young screaming
women, "Toto, Toto, Toto"
and I thought, wow, that's new.
Because before,
young women would kind
of come up to me and say,
"Oh, I love your racing."
But now they come up
like, "Oh, I love Toto.
I love your husband."
I'm like, "Yeah, so do I."
This is a season like no other.
Unbelievable start from Hamilton.
It's just insane.
Oh, they touched.
The growing audience was
used to the weak tweak drama
of the paddock and the pits,
but nothing could prepare fans
or teams for the 2021 season.
It culminated in beyond dramatic fashion
with the Driver Championship
decided in the final race
in Abu Dhabi on a judgment
call by the official.
What happened in Abu
Dhabi at the last race
really captivated people
even if you weren't
into motor sport.
I mean, the battle, how ferocious it got.
There are five lapped cars standing
between him and the race leader.
It's these magnificent brands.
It's these gladiators on
track giving it everything.
All the cars ahead of you are allowed
to overtake Hamilton.
It's just everything is
happening in that paddock.
No, no.
All the politics,
This is a mess.
the interaction among the stakeholders.
Mike, that is so not right.
That is so not right.
You think you have the
championship, then it's lost.
This is it.
At a certain stage in Jeddah,
the three races before the end,
I smashed my headphones because
I thought in that minute,
Lewis was break tested
and we lost championship.
And then you realize 10 seconds
later, it's actually on.
He just needs to win the race.
We are letting Netflix in
and they're seeing things
that otherwise if you look at
the pure sports broadcasting,
you wouldn't realize.
That by itself, Formula 1 is drama
and have always been
on track and off track.
There's too much at stake
and all that's being captured
by the lenses.
Toto says he hasn't watched
more than a couple episodes
of the show and has not
watched the final episode
of last season.
I certainly didn't want to be reminded,
but I felt we needed to watch it once.
And I watched of course the last episode
and Toto said, "Do you
think I should watch?"
I was like, "You know what, don't.
I've done it for both of us."
Yeah.
It's done and dusted.
The new season not only
brought little relief,
but more challenges.
New regulations required a new car design
and Mercedes simply got it wrong
in a way that no in-season
tinkering could fix.
A cost cap was introduced
in the 2021 season
and the jury is still
out on how much parity
it will bring to the circuit.
It did mean Mercedes
couldn't simply throw money
at its design mistake.
In the end, Mercedes failed
to win a ninth straight team title
and neither of its drivers
was ever in real contention
for the Drivers' Championship.
To make it worse for Toto and his team,
arch rival Red Bull added
a constructor's title
to Max Verstappen's second
straight Drivers' Championship.
The winning streak has
definitely come to an end
and I'm sure it's been a
really tough year for everyone
at Mercedes.
What goes to the very heart
of why they are so successful
is this idea of realizing that losing
is always just around the corner,
that the winning at some
point will have to end.
They were so rigorous in their approach.
They always analyze
everything, win or lose.
They were never complacent
and I think that sets them up really well
for future success.
So on race day, this office
is live onto the race track.
Toto's main office is at team headquarters
in North Hamptonshire, couple
hours outside of London.
This is where the majority
of the team employees work
and only a very small portion
ever see cars on the track
in person on a regular basis.
When I'm sitting on my
station at the racetrack,
all the engineers,
we talk to the various
channels and it can well be
that the engineers are
sitting very much here,
I wouldn't know the difference.
Right.
And whatever time zone
we are, you can see that it's 30 engineers
that are sitting here
working live on strategy,
giving us live information
about the state of the car
and all what we see on the
track is right in front of us
for them to see.
So my channels are basically open to,
I would say probably 50 engineers
that I could have a directed
discussion with if I wanted.
But also for us,
we have a a strict intercom
protocol that we follow
and you can say it's
almost like in an airplane.
Our ambition is to win every single one,
but in our sport it's about
physics and not mystics.
We got it wrong with the physics this year
and it is about how can we recover?
I see that as a real opportunity for us
because all of these people have been here
when they saw how good it was going
and now how difficult it can be
and that's gonna be an important learning
from them also in the future.
You will not take it for granted
that winning a championship
is easy.
So I believe there's always something good
in getting it wrong,
even though it feels
difficult when it happens.
But if I can't keep up.
No.
Have you ever been on a track?
I have never been on a track.
Never?
Never.
So what do I need to know?
Just hold on tight?
Hold on tight.
I like that we're racing Lewis though.
That's not so bad, no?
No, not a bad way to spend a Tuesday.
The Circuit of the Americas,
as the Austin racetrack is known,
is empty on this scorching summer day,
save for a few dozen Mercedes personnel
and some very excited Mercedes
sponsors from CrowdStrike.
Toto, along with Hamilton,
are hosting top CrowdStrike executives
for what feels like the
ultimate sponsor perk,
driving around an F1 track
with the world's most famous driver
and his also very famous boss.
It's more evidence of the big money
and big audience opportunity
for Mercedes and F1 in America.
US continues to fall in love
with the spectacle and drama.
In the past it would've
been a sticker on the car
and I give you visibility and
Formula 1 was very successful
at that because we are the
only true big global sport
and what has happened
over the last few years
that our audiences in the US
literally went through the sky.
We generate about a billion
and a half audience every year,
but it's involved to much more
of an integrated partnership
and it's not a sponsorship
anymore in that sense.
We have companies that
are working together.
We try to increase sales.
We utilize our network to
really help the business itself,
but our largest countries
are about 100 million live
audience, some of them.
And Austin is a good example,
more than 400,000 people
across the weekend
and the marketing side,
the visibility basically
is the icing on the cake
and just comes on top.
Wow.
I think we have been able to really shape
and identify our core values.
I feel we are in a good
place and having three races
in the us, one in Mexico
and one in Brazil.
It gives us a good footprint
in the Americas, beyond Europe,
Australia, Asia, and it
justifies it as a global sport.
This is a good setting.
Okay.
You can really go full throttle.
It'll get a little bit of rotation,
but it won't spin out.
Perfect.
With every lap, every
overseas trip in a season
that's only expanding,
next year there will be
24 races around the world,
Toto moves ever closer to a crossroads.
He signed a three year contract extension
at the end of 2020.
Moving out of day to day after
that and remaining an owner,
likely a vocal and interested one,
feels like a real possibility.
For now, his sole focus
as F1 gets more global
and more profitable is
getting Mercedes back on top.
I was a racing driver
turned finance person,
came back as a team
owner and team manager,
and I'm also the trainer.
I love the sport and this
is what I enjoy doing
at the moment,
but I feel when it's
the fifth time in a row
and you're finishing second or third,
rather than winning, these things,
these negative emotions still kick in.
At the end, the joint
target, the joint objective,
it's so massive that we just
need to remind ourselves
in these moments that
we just want the same.
We're just seeing the solution somewhere.
So we just need to get together
and say what is it that we want to do?
Data is important to develop a quick car,
but data don't make decisions.
Humans do.